so you're black and white technically
then I am what has that been like was
that kind of cool during like the BLM
movement was there like did you take
that in ways that other people probably
didn't take it or I don't even know how
to ask some of these questions I'm kind
of fascinated by race a lot right it's
interesting to me yeah I grew up in a
poor black and white area so it's what
city in Louisiana I grew up in like a
place called Covington Louisiana
um yeah Lee Harvey Oswald went to our
Middle School that was like our big
thing oh wow and um role model well
okay yeah yeah I mean yeah some people
think you did it some people don't but I
don't know even if he did he wasn't like
a good husband apparently so I don't
know I think people had views about him
around the area it was just kind of a
basic black and white town
so I've always I was always real
fascinated by race growing up you know
and like what went on and what it was
like and what it felt like you know
um
yeah so that's why I guess I was kind of
curious about oh so
uh
well I don't know the difference is that
my mom is West Indian it's Jamaican and
which is pretty significant so it's not
you know uh West Indian being an first
of all being an immigrant as opposed to
someone born here and West Indian
culture is very different from
African-American culture so you feel
it's a mixture of things like you feel
like a more the more of an immigrant
than you feel like uh
racial minority ah interesting so my you
know
my Jamaican cousins who live here will
sometimes talk about black people
but they're not talking about themselves
even though they're black right they're
talking about African-American talking
about African-Americans who they
consider to be you know
a separate group they're not the same so
there's there was a lot of that and West
Indians uh have been
you know the rels in this country are
relatively High status done very well
lots of professionals make a lot you
know as a group a coach the the the
group has done has really succeeded so
we're we're kind of a little bit on the
outside of uh of uh uh now there is oh
you know you get treated
in some ways you you do you still see
racism and better brunt of it but it's a
different reaction it's more like wait
what just happened as opposed to oh my
God that's happening again awesome
there's a big difference between those
two reactions you're not inheriting this
kind of Burden you're encountering this
burden for the first time right that's
that's strange yeah I'm not used to that
right yeah because I have friends from
like Nigerian stuff oh yeah they have
the same it's very similar right and
they'll talk about like a lot of times
how their experience is so different
than uh like a black person from
America's experience yeah but some cross
patterns because they are also have
black skin I think a lot about what did
like what BLM was like the black lives
matter what that movement and all what
it was like for
Society you know and what effects it had
on it and what
um
I don't know I think about that
sometimes you know or if we're still
figuring it out you know yeah I think
about like what my own perceptions were
during it what was going on
you know a lot of times I think
I think for one I didn't know black
people were as angry
mm-hmm you know I think that's something
that I think like oh I didn't know that
there was so much anger in the black
community you know about you know fear
of police and stuff like that or just
overall yeah I mean I could see how
there could be if you look back through
history you know especially in America I
wonder
if black people have always viewed
Society like in America
as like white Society I never thought
about that before you know because to me
Society I never thought about it as
white Society you know I've just thought
about it it's like this is the best way
of practices that things work that keep
us all kind of being able to stay alive
and move forward yeah
um I mean I I've been doing a a book
um about policing about the LAPD and um
among other things and it a lot of it is
about what the LAPD was like in the 40s
and 50s and
to your point its relationship to the
black community of to South Central to
the black community of Los Angeles and
it really helps to put something like
the George Floyd incident in perspective
or the central planners in perspective
which you realize that this has been
going on for Generations so
when you see the anger
of
you know
African-Americans over the George Floyd
killing
what you're seeing is a response not
just George Floyd it's the culmination
of
their parents saw
something like that happened when they
were growing up yeah and their
grandparents saw many things like that
happen with it and good great Grant you
know it's it's been going on for so long
that it's fresh what you're seeing is
kind of frustration as well as anger
it's this built up
can this it's not just I can't believe
this just happened it's I can't believe
this is still happening right right and
that's a very I can't believe this is
still happening is a much more
rooted powerful
bitter reaction then I can't believe
this just happened a one-off is we could
a one-off is something that goes away or
you know wow right this isn't about a
one-off right the way that that looked
everything about it yeah because your
DNA too I believe this stores pain from
past ex past lives past things right
like I quit sometimes like
like I have a lot of black friends that
are fast right they're physically fast
right and sometimes I think
well if you had like grandparents if you
had four generations of your family that
couldn't even run
that couldn't run if they wanted to
right like if you told them to run they
couldn't fit their check they couldn't
run
the first generation you get that can
run is gonna [__] fly right yeah like
it's almost it's like they have four
generations of wanting to run this is a
hypothesis in my head right that that in
their DNA in their cells that have
wanted to go and now they get to go
they're of course they're going to be
beyond the speed speed that you can't
really fathom right
um so I think it's that we can store
things inside of us right so that's why
I think it yeah I understand what you're
saying when you say that it's like yeah
this is just it's
it was a trigger for like a gun powder
that's kind of been built up in the
system for a long time yeah so I
understand that sort of thing
um
I think it made me think too like
yeah I wonder if black people sometimes
think that
that Society is like
not their society does that make any
sense you think
um like if they've ever
because like I don't look at society and
think like oh this is a white Society I
think this is just society and this is
how it works yeah but kind of like how
you say in your in the book and some of
the chapters like that different
expressions and things mean different
things in different places like I think
there's like in one of the first few
chapters you talk about
um they show pictures of men and women
in the way that their facial expressions
and how they in one place they're in in
American society they're really easy
people get them exactly right what these
expressions mean happy sad confused but
they show them to like a group of island
people and they have no I they're not
bad but they're not at it's all over the
place and for some of the Expressions
they don't even have a an answer yeah
um I don't know kind of all over the
place I think I'm just trying to think
like
how different I guess we can be you know
and maybe we don't
realize or
like
well I was just trying to yeah in that
part of the book I'm trying to explain
the kind of how culturally specific a
lot of
[Music]
facial expressions or things are and
that unless you understand those kinds
of of uh like for some people in some
cultures
uh if someone is looking away
and
uh it won't look at you in the eye when
they're talking that's taken as a sign
of
that they're lying or they're being
evasive in other cultures
looking away and when you're speaking to
you is a sign of respect like I'm
subservient I respect you know you're a
Elder I'm not going to challenge you by
looking you in the eye and like those
those are that's one very simple example
but you know
uh it's part of why the job of
understanding a stranger is as hard as
it is because you know we might bring a
set of assumptions about
Behavior or facial expressions to a
conversation and though they don't work
yeah we're dealing with somebody who has
a different set of reference points
um so that's really what I was what I
was getting that is that we
underestimate the kind of complexity
of of human responses
um there's so much of this like when
people say that
in a criminal trial so and so didn't
show any remorse well what does remorse
look like
um like
I don't know
I don't know what remorse looks like I
know how I might
I think I know how I might look if I was
feeling remorseful but I'm not even you
can't even see your own face when you
have that unless you're walking around
with a mirror in front of you yeah so I
don't know what I'm doing a lot of times
when I'm angry I don't look angry
I keep it in or a lot of times when I'm
happy I'm not smiling or like you could
go on and on so it's like you realize we
make so many mistakes by kind of
jumping to conclusions based on people's
facial expressions
um and that's one of the sources of
confusion that I write about in that
book
yeah it's that's it's it's really
interesting because there's just a lot
of things like you're like oh I never
really thought about that I never really
thought about
that some cultures too like and
especially like in America there's
always there's a lot of like black and
white tension right and I don't even
know if it's better now do you think
it's gotten better over
your lifetime do you feel like
yeah I think it is yeah I mean I think
people doing this book on
1940s LA and industries La it's a really
good reminder of just how bad things
were I mean
we have a long way to go but it's not
1948 anymore yeah up until the end of
the 1940s in Los Angeles
in over 80 percent of the city if you
were black you could not could not buy a
house in a white neighborhood wow like
there was a written in the deed of the
house it said this house cannot be sold
to a member of the you know
African-American was they didn't use
that phrase race right like are you
kidding me that is so much worse it's
why everyone lived where they lived in
L.A why did that why did the black
people of LA live in South Central they
couldn't live anywhere couldn't live
anywhere else not not that they didn't
want to or not that people would mean to
them legally couldn't live there because
the deed of that if they wanted to buy a
house and if you tried to buy a house
they would take you to court and they
would you'd have to sell it yeah wow
like things are better now yeah yeah
yeah things are better certainly like in
the uh framework right in the town and
like the the roots that we have in
society are like the new like you know
like the like laws and like it's
definitely that's better for sure I
think during like black lives matter I
always felt like we were all kind of on
the same page and then I felt like there
was this energy that like black people
wanted their own
Society almost in a way or they don't
feel like
like sometimes I just wonder like do can
cultures really figure it out over time
you know or will there always be some
things since you're from different races
and ethnicities that you just can't
really grasp you know like are there
some like Clues and like
communication modes or
if I make any sense kind of yeah
like I mean I guess I would say almost
optimistic over the long term about
these kinds of things well I think we're
all going to be beige in four
generations all right I believe that
right like I'm a beige power Advocate
you know like in four generations it's
going to be crazy to have even that we
were all think about race right but so I
just think about in the time being and
what it like feels like you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one